who told the story like he said these
executive meetings the guys are
grandma's dick
tim meadow he's not an idiot who plays
the president of the officer oh terry
cruz
terry crews yes [ __ ] badass terry
crews
he tells that story well i told the
story [ __ ] i've had hollywood execs
grabbed my dick three times
did they like what they felt or was it
like i told you it's very small
the point is is that the agility who
grabbed your dick
well i'm not going to say the story when
one of them died a couple but the point
was these were big hollywood
the dead do his name no i'm not gonna
the point is
i'm not a victim he don't snitch it
wasn't that big a deal the point is they
didn't do it sexually
it was an act of dominance so i get
terry crews like a badass nfl football
player some little white dude grabs his
dick from his wife
wants to kill him but me i was like what
the f i threatened to kick some guy's
ass the first time
and this is like a major hollywood
[ __ ] lawyer
to the top directors at a major movie
deal and all of a sudden i'm sitting
there go hey have a
have a safe drive back he goes don't you
[ __ ] threaten me and grabs my dick
in texas we say have a safe drive home
it wasn't like a threat the guy grabs my
[ __ ] dick i go what the [ __ ] is
he all [ __ ] freaks out it happened
two other times we're like you're just
these guys reach over and grab you
anyway
is i'm saying in hollywood it's an act
of dominance
and so and so so like if so like and the
thing is they're always like old [ __ ]
hunchback men
like you said it made you sick it's like
i have the [ __ ] talent i'm on a power
trip
yeah but you got the money you want me
to kiss your [ __ ] ass how about we
are successful how about that's my sign
not i gotta kiss because they're [ __ ]
man
no real [ __ ] badass dude wants you to
[ __ ] kiss their ass yeah
or nobody who actually thinks that they
have power wants to use it well i
i can fight okay i'm not going to grab
[ __ ] terry cruz's dick even if i
wanted to beat my ass
because that's like what are you doing
like walking up to a [ __ ] dude
like grabbing your dick if another wife
they're insecure it's an act of
dominance they're like
yeah i just need to confirm to myself
that i could grab somebody's dick
and they'll do nothing because that's
how powerful i am but i don't believe
i'm that powerful so i have to do it
just to make sure
i prove it to myself it's a form of rape
it's a little
little baby rape yeah it's a baby rape
yeah but not the sleep of a baby but
it's maybe right
but it is it is it is all babies were
raped during the filming
that is true only during the making of
the adrenal chrome
are we not drinking the adrena chromism
i'll take a drink with you guys all
right fine
i'll trust you out of the drink room you
said you fought back the first time what
happened the second
and third time i was like what the [ __ ]
and then it was a big [ __ ] scene and
everything he's like are you threatening
me you know
it was really weird and then and then
another time we were leaving a
restaurant this and this [ __ ] major
director producer
just goes and [ __ ] squeezed my and
laughed and jumped in an suv and drove
off i was like what the [ __ ]
and then it happened again like i'm in a
meeting kind of funny i'm in the media
boardroom this dude reaches over says
grab my dick and i'm like what do you
ever think it's you
bro no no i talked to a lot of people
what were you dressed like when i yeah
like how
whatever you were asking for yeah why
are you wearing i was better looking
back then but no these guys just grabbed
dicks
if you want to tell your real story
those are all stories i can tell you a
real story about i stuck into a secret
compound
and got chased around by gay dudes like
it was peppa pig
is this the one bohemian girl oh yeah
dude i love that
we were watching the video for the baby
grove thing that was hilarious
now did they ever get anything from you
oh they write me no no
dude can i ask you a question yeah the
uh the power thing because you see this
hat you see this happen all the time
like this sexual dominance but there's
like other other way that people use the
power
what is that a function of like what
what is what does that mean like
is is having tons of money not enough
like when you talk to these people i've
never spoken to these people that are
like that high or research them even but
like
when is is it just their bottomless pits
i think it's
yeah i think it's an ocd thing where
it's like
i love my wife but she'll literally look
at her makeup bag and like open it look
at it like walk around the house and
flip light switches on and like
before we leave like go back to your
room and like it's like well you know
women all do that like
what are you like mill around for 30
minutes before you leave like what does
this thing well
yeah women are great they mill around
the house and like check their makeup
and like you know make sure the door's
locked
these rich dudes are like not
comfortable in their own skin
and they just want to mess with people
because they
they get off on it they can dominate you
they just feel like
so and if you put up with it they get
really happy afterwards it's like a
weird ritual